[Music]
we're gonna do something a little
different today welcome back to an
exciting episode of not ask the boys but
we've got ask the girl
featuring cat over here
so uh we asked some fans some questions
that they want to ask kat so i've got
these lists of questions here and the
only way you can ask these questions is
to follow all of us on instagram because
you don't know which one of us is going
to ask for this round i asked on my
stories and i said we're gonna be asking
cass some questions so you little
perverts out there
ask away guys and girls okay we'll get
straight to it first question is how do
i convince my girl to do only fans i
know she can make bank
oh
my boyfriend actually convinced me
because i wanted to do it for a while i
want to make some extra money during the
pandemic and i felt like he was a good
gauge of telling me whether it was a
good idea or not because i was very very
one shy about it and then two i felt
very nervous about the judgment that i
would get from being on only fans
judgment from like a friends and family
or from the public uh i think mostly it
was uh the public and then people who i
worked with i know my family doesn't
care because i come from a family of
like
coffee shop girls so like not like none
of this is necessarily new to me and i
grew up watching a lot of people like be
into like import models and wanting to
be an import model when you're like in
high school that was a dream you want to
be like a
ashley abg goals yeah basically so it
wasn't new to me but i was in like in
the podcasting world it's very different
it's much more like
in our pocket a little more like
conservative like
more traditional
like values so i felt like i was going
to get judged really hard but they're
the most horniest because they're the
most repressed yes so they make the best
customers truly truly that's why i am
able to make a living but my boyfriend
just basically told me like
what doesn't matter like at the end of
the day you don't know anyone online you
hang out with like three people even if
like everybody in the world hated you
for it like who [ __ ] cares he's smart
about that that's true but it still
started with you though like you still
had an interest in wanting versus like
hypothetically just trying to convince
somebody who doesn't want to just try to
pimp his girlfriend out that's an uphill
battle don't want to do it this low-key
sounds like one you either want her to
make a bunch of money so like she can
spend it on you guys which like good for
you go get your bag king
um
but
or it sounds like you like the fetish of
or like this idea that your girlfriend
is like the hot girl online yeah
like are you lowkey a cuck is one of my
favorites oh
if you are then i think there's a cut
answer that question my boyfriend
there's no shame in it good for you if
you're a cop no more questions all right
another question says why is she so
mudda flippin sexy i don't know if
that's a third person thing that you're
supposed to answer maybe muda's in there
so joe supposed to answer why you're so
sexy i think that's what it is why she's
so sexy she was born that way yeah i
look just like my dad my dad's fine as
[ __ ]
i legit look just like my dad picture
your dad yeah that's the thing i posted
a photo of my dad a few months ago and a
bunch of people said wow you really look
like your dad and now i can't like
see your dad and you so like oh no way
now i think your dad is hot it's not
that like i'm not hot anymore it's that
my dad is now hot that's kind of hot
that's pretty tight but yeah if you jack
up off to me you're jacking off to my
father too so and he's proud without
what you will oh he's so happy at making
money he's still happy yeah
is cat a cat or a dog person uh uh
definitely a dog person but i think i
act more like a cat myself i'm much more
like you need to come to me
and
i like having people who have
personalities like a dog like my
boyfriend is a dog and i'm like the cat
that swats him away
how does your dog act though your new
dog your dog my dog he's such a little
[ __ ] boy he's like first of all he is
actually talking about the actual dog
not not my boyfriend dog she got a puppy
natural dog i have a puppy he is a
blonde mini dashin which is basically a
wiener dog he's about five pounds and
he's this little like designer dog
basically who can't drink tap water he's
going to get diarrhea
always has [ __ ] worms just drinking
voss
basically like he has to drink like
bottled water like us
wait if he drinks tap water he gets a
little tummy ache yeah a little tummy
ache a little tummy all right
but he's just bring him to the shelter
dude
i would not survive a day in the shelter
almost
a little bit i realized you rich dude
he is and he doesn't even realize it
he's so [ __ ] spoiled he has two
parents who don't work conventional jobs
who could be at home with him
he like cries and whines if he doesn't
spoiled [ __ ] he's spoiled as
[ __ ] you want to be disastrous do
anything for him where's your favorite
pho
i'm actually not that big
of a fellow fan my mom in my opinion
makes the best fog but my favorite food
is definitely out of the soups ah boom
boy boom boy
have you had not trying to move away i
have not oh you're gonna like they're
about to happen yeah they're like known
for boom ball way i do like fog
i just think it's overrated oh you got
better soups away is better than fall
that's a lot harder i think it's because
like you like more flavor
you like more things because boom boy is
just more wow yeah
pho is like more like it's like every
day you can eat and it's subtle but then
it gets boring
i need like more flavor yeah it's like
tea and coffee like coffee is more wow
but i like tea a lot yeah
wow
one of them is like a breakfast food in
vietnam right [ __ ] but you don't eat
boom boom away for breakfast
for breakfast there yeah yeah
bong it's like a dollar twenty-five like
broken rice plates where it's like
that's so hungry oh what's that one
where it's like a um rice paper crepe
that they put little more sale
so
is the little like gluttonous rice one
yeah it's like the little white dishes
with like the little pork rinds
i like that
i like that this uh socal versus norcal
uh
four different things i say norcal i
love norcal because i'm from there socal
is like my new home but i always feel so
like safe when i'm back in the bay it
feels like i get recharged i just don't
think i could live there right now i
feel like
what's the difference
uh nor cal is definitely much more chill
much more slow paced uh pace and then la
or socal in general i think is a little
more lively it's a lot more i wouldn't
even say fake i feel like if you're in
la or socal and you encounter a lot of
fake people it's the people you surround
yourself with because people from l.a
aren't like that it's like all the
transplants who come in here and give la
a bad neighbor thank you like if you're
surrounded by nothing but fake people in
la that's because that's that's who you
surround yourself with that's who you
choose to be around because we're real
la locals right here yeah
anthony's the only hollywood [ __ ] but
just
he was
unnecessary why is joe such a [ __ ]
well that's an interesting question
no okay
by anthony lee somebody says are there
any sales on your only fan somebody's
trying to get in on that
hey are they asian are they asian
they're always looking for the [ __ ]
deals bro
i just admitted he's the worst customer
alive let's say uh my i have two pages i
have a free page if you want to
subscribe to this on instagram
uh no one only fans i have two pages so
one is free and then what's the
difference free i don't post as much on
i use it really for promotional purposes
i'm trying to figure out i think i want
to start sending out pay-per-views on
there too just to like see what happens
how does that work
yeah because you make a lot of your
extra money in pay-per-view so i will
send out a locked message with like hey
uh like some sort of caption like for
fight night with my feet yeah like fight
night with my feet five dollars like pay
to unlock it and then you can see the
content behind the boxing gloves on the
pay-per-view so it makes additional
money but uh yeah if you watch public
commentators damn the system production
crazy but yeah if you want the free page
it's uh onlyfans.com catcall
that's the free one and then the uh
exclusive one with the good [ __ ] on it
is team so it's linked to employees uh i
do have some
employees i'll be yours
i'll get your coffee we could make your
company into a multi-million like right
now it's a million dollar company but we
can make it a multi multi-millionaire
yeah we got access to djinns
[ __ ] nick
he will sweet talk the [ __ ] out of all
your customers yeah you know he'll
double team in the replies with you yeah
[ __ ] bart
i don't know what he'll do but he'll do
something badass
you know what it is a lot of people will
do collabs on only fans dude imagine
bart and cat like oh unlock this
pay-per-view i'm collabing with like
bart for this month and it's like a
picture of his butt a picture of my butt
and then like you sell it for x amount
of dollars he's a booty double you are
the jk piece of meat
industry guys this is so much funner i
feel like we could all be at least your
focus group you know we could all give
you feedback
do people only fans go like let's say i
put my dick next to nick's collabing and
then we can make some money or is it
like we should just have sex together
because collabing right yeah you can do
that too
a lot of people do it different ways
sometimes they'll do like a tag for tag
so let's say we like anthony and i do a
photo shoot and then like half the
photos i use for my page the other half
he uses for his page
you can only get that content on his
page and then uh my page you can't we
don't cross mix no we tagged all
exclusive clubs or some people will do
like uh i will sell this pay-per-view
with anthony and he gets 10 20 whatever
amount percentage-wise we agree on so if
i sell like a hundred thousand dollars
worth of pay-per-views with my collab
with anthony he then gets a percentage
of that and we are doing this official
collab
i just figured out
how bart and nick can [ __ ] each other at
the same time
so
okay you point your dick down he was
workshopping i'm not circumcised but you
got the butt right we're docking and
then you go no no so you go like this
and then this holds the butthole so you
go like this and then you lock it in
right okay so like one person
is this facing this way with the dick
down yeah and then the other person is
facing up with a dick up and then so
it's like this oh
they go each going to hold yeah i think
you're over estimating my
length or underestimating the separation
of the gooch oh true or underestimating
the thickness of his ass yeah and how
much dick nick's gotta have to go
exactly people don't think about this
bro and it's the egg it's all about
angles if you don't got eight inches you
ain't touching me oh you got bigger
ass
it goes it goes this far out
only steve can read
yeah i don't think i can so what's your
favorite flavor from thrifty's ice cream
uh thrifty's no matter where i go i
always get coffee ice cream that's my
go-to it's really like a london
organizing coffee shop is the best the
best
have you ever gotten the chocolate uh
coffee lovers from cold stones yes i
have it's with the crushed heath bars
and all that stuff but yo why is nuts so
good with ice cream and chocolate and
coffee yeah i was going somewhere
different in my head
how do i get my long time girlfriend to
try new things in bed
um one i feel like girls are very
willing to try new things and generally
speaking uh you gotta make her feel
really comfortable and kind of open to
it
i feel like the only time i'm not like
the only time i don't want to try
something new is if i don't feel
comfortable in that environment yeah
that's that's the only time how do i get
her to let me [ __ ] her in the nostril
few things you know like
we don't know what this new thing is
yeah how do you also
how do you also stop a girl from lying
though from lying yeah the type of lying
when she's like you're the best thing
i've ever had
okay don't lie to my face because i
think girls are like this like it's like
oh what do you want to eat anything
right and that's not the damn line and
then you're like
okay what about this know about that
note about that and all right so i think
chicks are like that too where it's like
oh are you going to try anything new in
bed i'll try it just make me feel
comfortable that make you feel so
comfortable
see i think if you have one thing in
mind specifically like let's say you
really want to try i don't know throw
something out there
anal seems like okay
let's say like you really want to try
anal sex and your girlfriend doesn't i
say you gotta really kind of slowly and
gradually get her to that point like
slowly start like playing with her
butthole maybe put a tongue in a tongue
in a little pinky eating ass like make
it
seem like you don't want to try anal
right off the bat it's like oh let me
eat your ass and then just start like
doing more stuff with her ass like kind
of private stuff it's baby steps it's
really baby stuff what if you go like
you show up with a dildo in your ass
you're like if i could do it you can do
that
that's fair though but sometimes it
don't work
every 10 of the time it don't work every
time i want a blow job
every time i want to blow drop and ask
for a blow job i'm never going to get a
blow job like 99 out of 100 times you'll
never get a blow job if you ask for
[ __ ] but anytime i really want a
[ __ ] i'll ask if they want a [ __ ]
like hey you want me to eat you out
like throw them off a little bit you're
right because then like i think women
really have this feeling of like oh i
need to reciprocate i need to like meet
you halfway every
yes that's pretty tight in order to
receive you must give so if you want to
do anal at home with you let her peg
your butthole
put a strap on put
and hang it up on her her destroy your
[ __ ] anus hole yeah put your money
where your mouth is okay
is kat still in charge of brendan's
social media i am not actually uh i
stopped doing that for almost a year now
almost
i don't know he used to help out his
social medias one of the bigger parts of
my job working at fighter and the kid
was to handle social media and after a
while brendan wanted to get off social
media and i took over those
responsibilities so i would then like go
through those messages see if there are
any like business dollars no he's the
one fighting with fans no and now uh
someone else does it um you guys know
uh wait no it used to be gianni and now
it's christian oh christian does it okay
how come when i dm'd him [ __ ] you you
never replied i don't know i think
honestly i think that was around the
time i was taking over so i probably
just ignored it
but uh is this something can you refresh
it and bring the [ __ ] you back up to the
top you should have another message okay
oh i'll bring you back pin it oh wait
it's a dm right maybe you should have
said like [ __ ] you or something
new because everyone says that that's
true like even trolls say that like [ __ ]
you like you gotta say something
different yeah
that's my fault um like that's why i
[ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
or something like that you know like
gotta make it personal yeah
uh who's the better boss brendan or theo
um i'm always gonna say brandon
brennan's my guy he has looked out for
me since day one you worked with theo
yeah i worked with the eo for a little
oh did you uh king the sting during its
like year um but yeah like theo is great
but i i have such a soft spot for
brendan because when i first started
working with him it was straight out of
college he was my first job and i was
working part-time so i had to get like a
full-time job while i did that and i was
so broke at the time because i was
supporting me and then my ex-boyfriend
at the time that i got to a point where
i was working four jobs at once
literally like day after day of the day
what was what was your boy ex-boyfriend
doing nothing
literally nothing i was the biggest simp
i was like literally the biggest sound
see i've always heard these stories and
i've never been taken care of this way
me neither yeah
honestly i'm like i am like actually a
like a sugar mama i'm that type of
person where like i will take care of
you so you like do you do like platonic
sugar mama eating no that
asking for a friend
friends of friends you know so you're
doing all that yeah i was doing all of
that and then uh i told him at a certain
point like hey i think i'm gonna have to
quit the podcast because like i'm not
making enough money to just do this all
my other jobs are to support me being
able to do this he's like oh no don't
worry about it pay literally like paid
me more than enough what i needed to
survive and like and then some and just
had me do the podcast full-time like
this man has always worked out so it was
more like it was more like um
at that point it's like it isn't
it's not the price that you should have
got for what you were doing but out of
his own pocket he was just like here you
go like for the job i was doing i should
not have had been paid that much but
because he's like you know what like i
love working with you i'm gonna look out
for you i'm gonna pay you however much
you ask for and i just knew like i'm not
gonna ask too much of you i just like
need enough to be able to do this
and then he did that he always looks out
for me what is your ex-boyfriend was he
thankful uh kind of and then like not
really he was just like he would be
thankful no i think he would be like
he's [ __ ] you isn't he yeah no he was
like he's super open he my ex-boyfriend
was like okay with me being in like an
open relationship with him in college if
i wanted he's like that type of guy but
no who's this dude bro i don't know like
he didn't have a job no
he like moved to la to be with me and he
got really depressed because like he has
this idea of like oh i hate ellie he's
like one of those guys who like didn't
have much going for him here so he
decided to like hate the city yeah and
he didn't want to location depresses
you're the [ __ ] little [ __ ] yeah
that's like all the actors that work
waiting jobs and they they talk [ __ ]
about la and then they go back to [ __ ]
town i moved to albuquerque
it's like man you're [ __ ] a little
[ __ ] dude turkey's nice yeah they got
cool license plates
that's the stupidest [ __ ] i've ever
heard i went to this city and it was
horrible it's like where did you [ __ ]
go
yeah did you go to skid row like i did
live by skid row me too and it was fun
right little tokyo a lot of
entertainment yeah yeah
time to look out the window every now
and then jeez bro three in the morning
people flood curling screen
you like sierra movies yeah look outside
your window last question who do you
hate the most in jk who do i hate the
ball oh you have to give an answer
what's up
who do i hate the most
um
i feel like i'm always so
like everyone here is so cool but like i
have to say anthony
[Laughter]
i wasn't expecting this
i [ __ ] agreed i'm much more of like
growing up i was much more like a
jabberwockies fan
yeah gingers are cool too though when i
tell you about vietnamese girls dude
about videos no it's cool
they do have residency in vegas she's a
regular mouth hey she's like she's part
of the jk family now dude that was
amazing that was a great answer
oh my god
that's it dude
you